this is a you know I just got a say
right now this is a big night for me
because this really has been a dream of
mine since I was a little girl I've
always wanted to host the Academy Awards
and so it's a dream come true and I
assume for you in the audience that it's
a dream come true for you as well not
that I'm hosting that would be weird
because you didn't know me but for you
to be here and because if you had that
dream when you were kid then it would be
weird that we here on the same night
then you had a dream of me hosting and
then you're here also nominated I really
did I just I I grew up and I and I think
most people dream of winning an Academy
Award I had a dream of actually hosting
the Academy Awards and so let that be a
lesson to you kids out there aim lower
this really is though this has got to be
your favorite part of the night because
right now it's a level playing field you
don't really know who's gonna win unless
you're British and then you know you
have a pretty good shot but
a lot of British nominees a lot would I
say too many not here no at home in my
pajamas with a half a box of Chardonnay
and me who knows what I say but very
exciting night really exciting and
nerve-wracking you know for me and never
both more so for you probably because
you know tonight it could change your
life this is a very you know everything
is on the line for you it's a huge huge
night for you but it's best not to think
about that I guess so how can you not
it's the Oscars you have to think about
it but it's huge but it really is so
that's why it's my job of course to
relax you to put your mind at ease and
make you forget that this is a
make-or-break night for you just I
cannot imagine what you people are going
through I mean you're sitting out there
wondering you know if you're gonna win
and then if you win what you're gonna
say and because you all your peers are
watching and you shouldn't worry about
that you really should not because I'll
tell you what you should worry about
there's a billion people watching right
now so that's bigger and then you know
there's the pressure to keep your
speeches short and then you know let's
be honest it's not that we don't have
time for long speeches it's that we
don't have time for boring speeches
so if you don't have anything
interesting to say I suggest that you
make something up like you know I
remember when I was a kid growing up in
the Bronx even if you weren't from there
people love it when you come from the
Bronx they told me I'll never be an
actor cuz I couldn't read even if you
could you know tell them you lived in
your car oh they loved that but listen
don't even stress about that cuz maybe
you won't win you don't worry about that
at all either way you should just be
excited to be here really I mean I look
at Abigail Breslin over here
Abigail Breslin
[Applause]
[Music]
how are you eight ten nine she's a four
year old girl and just filled with joy
and hope and not worried about
competition she's just happy to be here
and that's how it is really for your
first nomination but then after you've
been nominated a few times you just want
to win really I mean am i right Peter
O'Toole Peter O'Toole nominated eight
nomination tonight eight nomination is
that right
[Applause]
you know what they say third time's a
charm
there's really you know I try to figure
it out there's no rhyme or reason to
who's gonna win how they figure these
things out because you know you can't
Jennifer Hudson Jennifer Hudson here
tonight and look at that
I tell you Jennifer Hudson was on
American Idol America didn't vote for
her and yet she's here with an Oscar
nomination that's amazing that's
incredible and then Al Gore is here
America did vote for him and then
complicated and then Leonardo DiCaprio
is here hi Leo I don't have a joke I
just thought the ladies wanted to look
at him for a second so look at you
[Applause]